[Applause]
okay for my soulmate mm-hmm
Kobe was known as a fierce competitor on
the basketball court the greatest of all
time a writer and Oscar winner and the
black mamba but to me he was Coco my
booboo my baby boo
my papi chulo I was his VB his
principessa is Reina his Queen mama mama
and his whiskey menisci fabulous key I
couldn't see him as a celebrity nor just
an incredible basketball player he was
my sweet husband and the beautiful
father of our children he was mine
he was my everything Kobe and I have
been together since I was 17 and a half
years old I was his first girlfriend his
first love his wife his best friend his
confidante and his protector he was the
most amazing husband Kobe loved me more
than I could ever Express or put into
words
he was the earlybird and I was an idol I
was fire and he was ice and vice versa
at times we balanced each other out he
would do anything for me
I have no idea how I deserved a man that
loved and wanted me more than Kobe he
was charismatic a gentleman he was
loving adoring and romantic he was truly
the romantic one in our relationship and
looked forward to Valentine's Day and
our anniversaries every year he planned
special anniversary trips and a special
traditional gift for every year of our
marriage
he even had made my most treasured gifts
he just thought outside the box and was
so thoughtful even while working hard to
be the best athlete he give to me the
actual notebook and the blue dress
rachel mcadams wore in the notebook
movie when i asked him why he chose the
blue dress he said it was because it's
the scene when Ali comes back to Noah we
had hope to grow old together like the
movie we really had an amazing love
story we loved each other with our whole
beings - perfectly imperfect people
making a beautiful family and raising
our sweet and amazing girls a couple
weeks before they passed Cobie sent me a
sweet text I mentioned how he wanted to
spend time together just the two of us
without our kids because I'm his best
friend first we never got the chance to
do it we were busy taking care of our
girls and just doing our regular
everyday responsibilities but I'm
thankful I have that recent text it
means so much to me
Kobe wanted us to renew our vows he
wanted Natalia to take over his company
and he wanted to travel the world
together we had always talked about how
would be the fun grandparents to our
daughters children he would have been
the coolest grandpa Kobe was the MVP of
girl dad's or MBD he never left the
toilet seat up
he always told the girls how beautiful
and smart they are he taught them how to
be brave and how to keep pushing forward
when things get tough and we could we
retired from the NBA he took over
dropping off and picking up our girls
from school since I was at home pregnant
with Bianca
and just recently home nursing Capri
when Kobe was still playing I used to
show up an hour early to be the first in
line to pick up an authority on Gianna
from school and I told him he couldn't
drop the ball once he took over he was
late at one time and we most definitely
let him know that I was never late so he
showed up one hour and 20 minutes early
after that he always knew there was room
for improvement and wanted to do better
he happily did carpool and enjoyed
spending time in the car with our girls
he was a doting father a father that was
hands-on and present he helped me bathe
biank and Capri almost every night he
would sing them silly songs in the
shower and continue making them laugh
and smile as he lathered them lotion and
got them ready for bed he had magic arms
and could put Capri to sleep in only a
few minutes he said he had it down to a
science
eight times up and down our hallway he
loved taking Bianca to fashion I are
gonna watch her play in the koi pond
area and love taking her to the park the
most recent visit to the koi pond was
the evening before he and Gigi passed he
shared a love of movies and the
breakdown of films with Natalia he
enjoyed renting out theatres and taking
Athaliah to watch the newest Star Wars
movie or Harry Potter films and they
would have movie marathons and he
enjoyed every second of it he loved her
typical tearjerkers - he liked watching
stepmom steel magnolias and Little Women
he had a tender heart Koby somehow knew
where I was at all times specifically
when I was late to his games
he would worry about me if I wasn't in
my seat at the start of the of each game
and would ask security where I was at
the first time out of the first quarter
and my smart ass would tell him that he
wasn't going to drop 81 points within
the first 10 minutes of the game I think
anyone with kids understands that
sometimes we can't make it out the door
on time and eventually he was used to my
tardiness and balled out the fact that
he could play on an intense professional
level and still be concerned by making
sure we made it to the game safely it
was just another example of how family
came first to him he loved being
Gianna's basketball coach he told me he
wished he would have convinced Natalia
to play basketball so that they could
have spent even more time together
but he also wanted her to pursue her own
passion he watched no Thalia play in a
volleyball tournament on her birthday on
January 19th and he noticed how she's a
very intelligent player he was convinced
she would have made a great point card
with her vision of the court and he told
me that he wanted Bianca and Capri to
take a basketball when they get older
see he could spend just as much time
with them as he did with Gigi and Kobe
always told Bianca and Capri that they
were going to grow up and play
basketball and mix they ass up now they
won't have their daddy and sister here
to teach them and that is truly a loss I
do not understand but I'm so thankful
Toby heard Coco say Dada he wasn't going
to be here to drop Bianca Capri off at
pre-k or kindergarten he isn't going to
be here to tell me to get a grip V when
we have to leave the kindergarten
classroom or show up to our daughters
doctor's visits for my own moral support
he isn't going to be able to walk our
girls down the aisle or spin me around
the dance floor while singing PYT to me
but I want my daughters to know and
for the amazing person husband and
father he was the kind of man that
wanted to teach the future generations
to be better and keep them from making
his own mistakes he always liked working
and doing projects to improve kids lives
he taught us all valuable lessons about
life and sports through his MBA career
his books his show detail and his puny
x' podcast series and we're so thankful
he let those lessons and stories behind
for us he was thoughtful and wrote the
best love letters and cards and Gigi had
his wonderful ability to express her
feelings and to pay paper and make you
feel her love through her words she was
thoughtful like him they were so easy to
love everyone naturally gravitated
towards them they were funny happy silly
and they loved life they were so full of
joy and adventure God knew they couldn't
be on this earth without each other
he had to bring them home to heaven
together babe you take care of our
chichi and I got Nani Bibi and Coco
we're still the best team we love and
miss you boo-boo and Gigi you both rest
in peace and have fun in heaven until we
meet again one day we love you both and
miss you forever and always mommy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]